this program is brought to you by Emory
University
very shortly in 1982 a clear infectious
disease pattern came from surveillance
where cases were first found in gay men
and then injecting drug users
heterosexual partners of people with
AIDS children born to women who likely
had been either infected or partners of
people who are infected and finally
people with hemophilia who had exposure
to many thousands of donors and
untreated blood products and that was
the key of someone like Ryan White who
was a young teenager kicked out of
school by fearful colleagues and parents
because he had a disease that he
acquired through blood products and it
was his courage and the courage of Alton
John and the courage of Michael Jackson
and others who went to him and said he's
our boy to let him back into school that
led him finally to get a ziti for a few
short months before he died at age 19
wanting to be only a teenager like
everyone else not wanting to be a saint
or a hero and he made such a difference
that there was legislation specific
legislation only for end-stage renal
disease now for a disease that allowed
the uninsured the disenfranchised to get
the services they need including medical
care you know people say it isn't fair
for HIV because everybody has health
insurance it'd be nice if everybody had
health insurance period but it's
certainly not to blame that because of
Ryan White Kennedy in and others that
the Ryan White Care Act occurred I'm
reminded that ryan white would be 40
years old today if he was still alive I
wonder if he'd have gray hair and what
he had to say about all this if he only
lived to heart became available
the preceding program is copyrighted by
Emory University